S K R A T T A  D U
Förlorar du, mannen.
OUH,   U A O H
30% percent off GFUEL,
if you enter the code "PEWDIEPIE".
At the checkout, only for a limited time.
*Damn i am actually really good at this*
Fr*cking do this guys, we are checking out
this new thing, the rule is very simple.
Skratta du, förlorlar du.
If you want to accept this challenge,
then all you have to do is very simple.
Smash like on this video.
Go buy the entire stock of GFUEL [Sponsorship 100]
But, you get 30% percent off so you can buy 30% more.
If you enter the code "PEWDIEPIE"
And you have to say "PEWDIEPIE"
When you enter the code.
Now without further a do.
If you have done this, we can move on.
Lets, fr*cking do this, lets just
A U G H  *explosion*
"It has to be a god damn clue somewhere."
"Its probably is staring in my face."
"This kid is going to die, and I'm going mad at circles!"
Basically youtuber acting. *Chuckles*
OH   "All packed and ready to go"
"What are you talking about?"
*Chuckles* "The investigation is over, we know who did it. "
"We no longer need your services anymore, Norman." *laughs*
"So you can ride your files all way back to Washington."
"I'd be lying if I said I was gonna miss ya."
Incredible  "The investigation isn't over. You have absolutely nothing on Mars."
OH
I wish there was more of these.
They're so good.
When you don't want to do homework but physics is forcing you down into the chair.
*laughs*
Why is that funny? Jesus Christ.
Me when thinking if I should eat the last slice of pizza now or save it for later.
*laughs*
That's where that meme is from!
I've seen it all the time.
You see this stupid screenshot.
Right.
*laughs*
Should I eat it now or later?
But, if I eat is now it's going to be hot and delicious.
I can save it for later as well.
But, if I eat it later then it won't taste as good.
But I'm really not that hungry now.
Aw, geez!
Oh my gosh! It looks like I'm already failing this challenge.
Hurry up! I must replenish my health with GFUEL.  [again Pewds?]
Oh wow!
All my health is back! Thanks Brad!
[That's what I thought.]
I like how Brad
*laughs*
Brad. Brad was the one that told me about GFUEL.
He's been wanting to get sponsored by GFUEL for so long.
*laughs*
And in comes Pewdiepie! AYE Enter the code "PEWDIEPIE"!
You're not getting any GFUEL, Brad.
Oh, I'm not getting any GFUEL.
I'm not getting any GFUEL.
Me
I'm not getting any
GFUEL
ME
COOME ON MAN
Oh my god, yes.
This-This clip.
"That's the cutest f*cking thing I've ever seen in my entire life."
*yelps*
*laughs*
Wha- no one warned her about this?
Seriously?
What a bunch of a**holes in the chat. *laughs*
So good.
Why is she crying before?
*laughs*
Everyone has been pointing out how she sounds exactly like a car alarm as well. So good.
*the girl yelping*
Moving on guys. How are you doing?
Don't care. Let's keep going.
*sad music* "Can I say it just once before I go?"
"ye-yeah bro"
"Thanks my n-"  *sad music*
yea- *Gasps*
NOO
AAHAA
AAH that's so sad
Can we sound like a car alarm. Now that's actually sad.
*the girl yelping*
Woah
Woah what the fr*ck.
AA It keeps going.
WHat
Okay that's pretty epic.
Does he have a twin or am I stupid? I can't tell.
No no no no no
It's a- It's a- It's a mirror. Its like a mirror- the. It's like a mirror trick.
I don't know- I'm pretty smart. So the way they did it was like with mirrors. I don't know if you heard of those.
But that's how he did it, basically. There's not many of him or anything like that
Good joke. Okay- aa *laughs*
I'm really not do too well on this challenge.
It would seem that it's time to GFUEL up, boi.
*gulping noises*
Bet you're jealous now, Brad. hah Who's got a GFUEL sponsorship.
HAhe
Cry more, Brad. All though, to be fair, Brad. You just gotta enter the code "PEWDIEPIE"
and you get 30% off.
That's a great deal!
That's a good deal.
Not saying the n-word for an entire minute challenge.
Oh damn
"But it was clear that pain hadn't receded at all and the doctor offered up up a suggestion." *chuckles*
"Let's go to the hospital."
"That was-"
"-unbelievable.
*chuckles* "You look a lot like a man now though. Just so you know."
*laughs* That's  how you become- *laughs*
"I grow an extra testicle."
It's the phase we all have to go through to finally grow up and become a man.
What is he actually doing. I'm so confused.
* deep voice* "This my voice, one day in California.
Oh god another one of these. "Ooh what's up dude. Two weeks in California."
Okay let's get to it.
"Haha Hope you have a great day eh."
Alright.
"This is my voice two years in California." *girly voice*
"IT IS MA' AM! IT IS MA'AMAaa"
*laughs*
YEess!
I mean no. That's horrible.
*chuckles*
I feel like it's only funny if you seen the reference and I'm not showing the reference.
Moving on. "Hit or miss."
"I guess the never miss huh"
*Pewds and the guy gasps*
"You gotta boyfriend?"
"I get he doesn't kiss ya."
Oh my god!
"He'll find another girl and he won't miss ya"
This is fake sadly. Wow, really?
Must be some kind of genius.
"Self-explanatory drinking fountain."
Wait sorry. What did he say?
Self-explanatory drink fountain.
"Take one." Take one, okay.
*choking on water*
*laughs*
I love the gorilla laugh. HAoh It actually worked?
*Laughs*
*Gorilla laugh
*laughs*
See this is what I'm talking about
memes and tik tok were all invented to hold the progression of humanity.
Instead of coming up with useful ideas that progress humanity forward.
Instead, we come up with this kind of stuff.
*chuckle*
For the sake of memes.
*Gorilla laugh*
Okay listen to me guys. Gotta put on my tin foil hat.
Memes was created by aliens.
Sounds crazy?
It was created to hold the progression of mankind so that aliens that lives far up in galaxies far away.
Have time to  reach us and invade us. So by the time the reach us, our technology has not advance at all
because all we did for a hundred billion years was make meme instead.
Think about it.
Shroud gets called out by Pewds.
"That's me watching Pewds"
"YEess"
I wish I could see both of the shots at the same time
*clasp*
"HEY SHROUD! HIT SUBSCRIBE GOD DAMN IT! WHAT ARE YOU DOING!"
"I got you. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I was  subscribed on my other seven accounts"
That's great.
*laughs*
HEY SHROUD! SUBSCRIBE IN YOUR OTHER ACCOUNTS! GOD DAMN IT!
WHAT YOU CALL YOURSELF A GAMER! HUH
I'll keep checking in.
"I-love-you!"
Awh I've seen this
"No-thank-you"
Aye look, who found the video of me confessing to Marzia for the first time? [oof]
*laughs the pain away*